so when you think about what's changed
over the last year or so since we last
talked uh there's been a bunch of
changes in growth and and um uh kind of
positive developments with foundry and
then also there's been absolute chaos in
the mining
industry in general maybe let's start
with kind of the market itself and how
you evaluate what's transpired over the
last 12 months or so and then how has
that allowed you guys to navigate this
and kind of where are you both from a
size standpoint and then also kind of
what you are doing from a service
standpoint where is most of your
attention or energy right now
yeah you know the mining space moves
incredibly fast um it's like
every 30 days 60 days it's it's changing
and it's evolving
and uh which makes it super exciting i
would i always say that you know about
four years ago i pivoted my whole career
to go into the mining space i don't
think i could ever go back to the
traditional world uh it just moves way
too slow
so on the mining front um we were we're
fortunate we bet a little counter
cyclical so
you know 18 months ago we were buying
all the equipment we could prior to um
the having
and uh
and as as we went through that process
we we launched our equipment financing
business to really help
support other miners in north america
um what we to be honest with you what we
didn't anticipate was the
uh wafer shortage so
bitmain and micro bt they work with tsmc
and samsung
they're on the latest generation chips
they're competing now with apple and you
know the best technology
to get access and there just wasn't as
many miners available as we
thought
so they kind of constraint the market
and then
what we
also didn't anticipate was just the last
90 days when
uh
china shut down mining you know
they've always threatened to do it
there's always they've always
done it in in in certain pieces but not
like wholeheartedly across the board and
that just
sent shock waves through the industry
and now what we're seeing is there's a
surplus of equipment
but there's no place to plug them in
and uh that's like changing the the
dynamic of of the of the industry once
again so it's you got to be you got to
move fast
in this space
when you think about the china decision
uh i think everyone agrees they've
always threatened it they've always
alluded to it but this time it was
serious
100 of miners out of china eighty
percent how do you evaluate you know
who's left and and uh who decided to
move on and then also what is where are
those people going in general is it
north america are they finding a home
somewhere else
yeah so the way i would so i won i think
it was a big strategic mistake on
china's part and and hopefully someday
they're gonna regret this
um i would say probably 80 percent of
the miners had to shut their operations
down there's still probably 20 percent
in china
we're starting to see some of them turn
back turn back um on their machines you
know hash rates starting to increase
um pretty quick
uh
and and what the way the chinese miners
describe it now in china is it's kind of
like a green market so
if you're willing to take a little risk
you can still mine but at any point in
time you're gonna get you could get shut
down most of the time they're like
paying off the local authorities or
something to let them mine the bigger
miners have now
um
they're basically focused on
decentralizing their
um their machines around the world and
the chinese are going pretty much
anywhere they can to find space to plug
in and i think what they're
finding in north america is the fact
that you know most of the big guys have
they bought their own equipment or
they've got customers that already
bought their equipment
their build-out schedules are booked for
literally the next six to nine months so
they're gonna the chinese miners are
gonna have a hard time plugging their
machines in
in north america to any kind of scale so
they're doing a lot of work in in
eastern europe kazakhstan even into
russia um
and and really they're going anywhere in
the world they can to find cheap power
when you talk about all those miners
looking for power uh but they're not
really being enough power is there
something that um you're kind of
pointing your finger to and saying this
is the solution is it pursuing you know
gas flaring is it trying to find more
renewables or clean energy or is it
literally just no the power producers
have to
get the lead time in order to get this
stuff up running and kind of ready for
the miners like what what solves that
kind of uh if you will supply demand
imbalance
time
you know you can't
it's one of these things where you can't
just
you know we see all these pitch decks we
see all these miners these announcements
and they're like hey we're gonna
we're gonna turn on a 100 megawatt
facility
you don't turn on 100 megawatt facility
in a week or a month or three months i
mean that's that's like a six to nine
months journey
and that's if you start if you started
six months ago right so it's hard to get
the infrastructure equipment now there's
supply chain delays it's hard to get
plugged into the network right like you
just don't walk into some place and say
hey i want 100 megawatts you know they
have to do all kinds of grid analysis
there's usually regulatory approvals you
have to go through there's a lot that
that takes place so it's going to take
time to get this plugged in
what we're seeing is energy companies
are now
waking up to the fact that that
this bitcoin mining is not going away
it's a legitimate industry
and there's this massive base load
that's intermittent
and they're they're starting to think
about how do they plug that into their
existing
infrastructure or their new projects and
kind of marry bitcoin mining together
with with power production and i think
that's just for me that's super
fascinating in terms of
how that's going to play out over the
next four or five years
um so i think it's just gonna be bigger
and bigger players hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it